über die letzten acht Videos haben wir
die verrücktesten Methoden getestet um
irgendwie an Kohle für einen Porsche 944
zu kommen von Methoden am Schreibtisch
für die wir nichts brauchten außer
unseren Laptop bis hin zu Hunderten
Kilometer auf der Autobahn oder ins
kühle Nass auf dem Golfplatz hat nichts
so gut funktioniert wie das was wir
heute herzlich Willkommen zu ungeplanten
krassesten Folge der gesamten Reihe von
Porsche Trader und damit herzlich
Willkommen zu Folge 2 von Porsche
Skulpturen verkaufen um einen echten
Porsche kaufen zu können wenn die Folge
1 noch nicht gesehen habt dann klickt
einfach hier oben und bevor wir jetzt so
richtig rein Starten der ein oder andere
erinnert sich wahrscheinlich noch dass
wir hunderte von kostenlosen Porsche
Trailer Golfbällen in einem der Golfball
tauchvideos Verlust haben dieses Mal
gibt es wieder was ähnliches also bleibt
bis zum Ende dran um das nicht zu
verpassen wie konnte ich da nicht drauf
kommen wir haben in dem Poster Video
richtig reingekackt Online Werbung also
mit Werbung die wir produziert haben und
dann Performance mäßig ausgespielt haben
also Geld dafür ausgegeben dass eine
Menge Leute das sehen die immer weiter
optimiert wird
bei den Leuten ankommen die am besten
zum Produkt passen aber warum meine
warum buchen Leute mich warum werden
placements gebucht ganz einfach weil man
genau dort über eine persönliche Note
bei einem Social Media influencer bei
einer direkten Zielgruppe ankommen kann
die ziemlich genau zu definieren ist
wenn Leute ein bestimmtes Thema besetzen
so zum Beispiel bei unseren Modellen bei
den Porsche Modellen die Autos meine es
ist doch relativ klar wer so ein Produkt
von uns kaufen würde und dafür Geld
ausgeht Leute die entweder sehr Porsche
begeistert sind und vielleicht schon
immer einen Porsche haben wollten sich
aber nicht leisten können im Prinzip ich
oder Leute die ihre Wohnung schicker
machen wollen aber vielleicht nicht
wissen wie sie es machen sollen also
suchen wir jetzt Influenza die genau
diese beiden Themen besetzen erst die
Idee gekommen ist ist Rafi ein noch
relativ kleiner Creator den man aber
kennt wenn man über die letzten Jahre
tomato liegt viel verfolgt hat und der
in letzter Zeit immer wieder ziemlich
coole Reals zu einrichtungsthemen Macht
und seine Bude auf Vordermann bringt
etwas größer aus dem Gebiet oder
deutlich ein bisschen größer Sarah
Hartmann ziemlich cooler Content weiß
ich nicht ob das Porsche Modell weil das
ja schon ein relativ männliches Thema
ist jetzt wirklich zu ihr und ihrem Stil
passt und sie wird im Zweifelsfall auch
deutlich teurer sein wäre aber auch cool
Fragen auf jeden Fall an und schauen ob
was draus wird in der autobabel ganz
klar JP Performance Hamid Matthias mal
mit die sind aber alle so groß dass ich
glaube dass die unsere Mail nicht mal
mit dem Arsch angucken auf der anderen
Seite gibt es eine Menge Leute die das
Thema auch mit etwas geringere
Reichweite und dafür noch mal deutlich
persönlicher vertreten also so jemanden
wie movo oder und da setze ich die
meisten Hoffnung rein passt ein Kanal
der sich fast hauptsächlich um Porsche
dreht der ist wirklich schafft die Liebe
zu Porsche in jedem seiner Videos
rüberzubringen und das in höchster
Qualität wenn wir es bei ihm auf dem
Kanal auf Instagram auf Twitter auf
Youtube irgendwohin schaffen sollten
könnte das richtig knappen aber auch bei
Momo male ich mit ziemlich große Chance
habe irgendwie das Gefühl dass die
autobabel eine Babbel ist die Kohle
ausgeht also machen wir uns dran wir
schreiben eine Mail und dann geht's ab
natürlich schreibe ich das nicht selber
sondern die AI macht das sehr geehrter
Name des Empfängers wir sind begeistert
von ihrem Engagement und ihrer
Leidenschaft für Autos insbesondere für
Porsche unser Team hat ein wunderschönes
handgefertigtes keramikmodell dieses
legendären Autos geschaffen die sind
überzeugt dass sie geil und noch viel
weiter geht die Mail von Chat GPT die
wir jetzt benutzen um alle möglichen
Leute anzufragen und während das
passiert kümmern wir uns um hochwertigen
Versand um eigenen social media content
auf tik tok und Instagram und noch
vieles weiteres und mit dem Versand
starten wir im Prinzip haben wir uns ja
schon deutlich einfacher gemacht indem
die Modelle deutlich kleiner geworden
sind so sieht das jetzt aus das müssen
wir verpacken ganz wichtig natürlich ist
darf nicht kaputt gehen und irgendwie
soll es noch gebrannt sein dafür haben
Pakete gekauft dicker gekauft um die
Pakete zu Bränden und
Farbe Rap
[Musik]
also den Modell passiert so auf jeden
Fall nicht würden wir jetzt wirklich auf
so eine Magnetbox oder was schwarzes
oder irgendwas mit Samt oder so gehen
wollen verlieren wir richtig Kohle weil
das einfach richtig viel kostet absolut
unendlich habe deswegen machen wir das
so
[Musik]
auf jeden Fall klar unsere Sticker
ja cleanes einfaches Paket kostet uns
nicht zu viel Zeit zu verpacken das
müssen wir natürlich auch immer bedenken
sollten wirklich mehrere Bestellungen
reinkommen können wir natürlich die
Pakete hier so einfach schon vorbereiten
Sticker drauf halten die aufkleben die
eine Seite schon zu und haben dann
fertige fertig beklebte Pakete dann rein
rein rein rein rein rein zu machen
Sticker drauf und abfahren dafür müssen
wir aber erstmal einige Modelle
verkaufen und deswegen geht es jetzt für
uns rein in die tiktok und Instagram
Produktion
lange Zeit haben wir alle unsere tiktoks
mit dem PC geschnitten einfach weil wir
es von Youtube so gewohnt dieses Mal
allerdings nutzen wir Caputh die App von
tiktok selber die unheimlich Power voll
ist was wir bis dazu noch nicht wussten
also jeder von euch wird das Wissen der
unter 16 ist sondern einfach das dass
das da muss man 5000 Jahre warten weil
jetzt würde man auf dem Handy schneiden
im Prinzip gibt's Vorlagen die wir mit
unseren eigenen Videos befüllen und so
innerhalb von wenigen Sekunden zu
perfekten Ergebnisse kommen ich habe
gerade das erste Top veröffentlicht
guckt euch das an 2 Minuten Arbeit
[Musik]
das ist wirklich geisteskrank
egal du kannst aus demselben Material 15
tiktoks machen einfach hoffen dass eins
Pop genauso machen wir das jetzt
gut es geht aber nicht nur viel
schneller sondern es sieht auch nach
tiktok aus und es fühlt sich auch nach
tik tok an und auch wenn sich das
erstmal nicht mega krass anhört ist das
völlig verrückt dass das mit dem Bus
gemacht hat krank interior Club
Bestellung live order Porsche Modell das
tiktok was ich war fünf Minuten
hochgeladen habe vielleicht direkt
gezogen keiner weiß es das Ding ist
genauso eine viel einfachere digitale
Lösung gibt es nicht nur für den Schnitt
von tiktoks sondern auch für jeden von
euch wenn es darum geht früher dann
später zu denken nämlich klagt der
Partner des heutigen Videos immer dann
wenn es darum geht im Alter sorgenfrei
leben aber warum ist die Altersvorsorge
jetzt überhaupt schon wichtig ich meine
die meisten von euch sind in einem Alter
in dem man sich am liebsten als
allerletztes damit beschäftigen möchte
doch je früher man sich darum kümmert
und je früher euch das klagt wird ja das
habe ich mir selber ausgedacht desto
besser könnt ihr im Alter davon leben
die Zahlen zeigen die Zweifel kommen
nicht von ungefähr nur 23% der deutschen
Bevölkerung glauben ihren aktuellen
Lebensstandard im Ruhestand noch halten
zu können eins ist aber sicher die
einzige Sorge die man sich wirklich im
Alter machen will ist was man zu Mittag
ist oder wohin man in den Urlaub fährt
und nicht ob man übers
Renteneintrittsalter hinweg noch weiter
arbeiten muss um über die Runden zu
kommen was tatsächlich jeder fünfte über
55 tut willst du im hohen Alter also
deine Reisen deine Hobbys und dein
Lebensstandard im allgemeinen weiter so
durchziehen können dann ist eine private
Absicherung absolut zu empfehlen klar
ist dafür eine super Option denn sie
beraten Euch individuell also völlig
egal ob privat Absicherung betriebliche
Riester Rente oder sogar ETF-Fonds im
Beratungsgespräch findet ihr die
perfekte Lösung mit dem Code Dave oder
über diesen QR-Code erhaltet ihr durch
das Hochladen von drei bestehenden
Versicherungen bis zu 45 € in Form eines
best church Gutschein unheimlich vielen
Partnern einlösen könnt darunter adidas
Zalando oder Ikea ladet euch jetzt also
die Klage runter denkt früher an später
und schaut wie euch jetzt schon gegen
Altersarmut absichern wird vielen Dank
an klar fürs unterstützen die das
Projekt und euch viel Spaß weiter mit
dem Video
wir haben die erste Zusage für plays mit
von Momo wir haben alle Daten bekommen
wie viele Story views er macht und dass
er bereit ist Stories für uns zu machen
was richtig geil ist jetzt gilt es für
uns noch einen Preis auszuhandeln einen
Preis mit dem wir da Kurse mit dem Erda
Core ist und dann zu hoffen dass wir
wirklich verkaufen ich will hier
natürlich keine Informationen
veröffentlichen die ich nicht
veröffentlichen soll also sage ich euch
nicht wie viel Story Reviews er macht
aber was er macht er macht deutlich mehr
als ich gedacht hätte und was es kostet
kann ich euch natürlich auch nicht sagen
am Ende gibt's wieder eine
Kostenaufstellung wo alle unsere Kosten
drin sind so dass ihr nicht ausrechnen
könnt wie viel seine Stories kosten aber
er macht das Ding ist man könnte jetzt
meinen dass ich kenne Moria persönlich
das ist das irgendwie mit dem persönlich
aber es liegt tatsächlich einfach über
Mail also wir müssen nicht irgendwie so
unter der Hand fürs Projekt gemacht
sondern es liegt einfach über Mail und
ich habe ihm ganz normal geschrieben und
wir verhandeln jetzt im place mit ohne
dass er weiß dass ich dahinter stecke
was ziemlich geil
die ersten tiktoks sind live und wir
konnten ein Porsche Modell und ein
Graffiti Modell in einer Bestellung und
ein Porsche Modell das richtig geil ist
weil es nach Rabatt den wir auf der
Website geben 143 €, und einmal 112 €
und 41 Cent für das Porsche Modell sind
also über
250 Euro Umsatz mit dem ersten tiktok
die verpacken mir
[Musik]
sieht aus wie so ein Päckchen
unsere offiziell erste order mit
interior Club der Witz ist ja die Poster
verkaufen weiter einfach so weil wir
auch weiter tiktoks hochgeladen haben
und jetzt hoffen wir aber weil die Marge
hier natürlich viel viel höher ist die
auch weiter zu verkaufen
aber wie hoch ist die Marge eigentlich
wir kaufen 25 Kilo Säcke Keramik
Gießmasse das kostet uns 85 € und ergibt
sowas wie 15 Modelle dazu brauchen wir
noch 12 1/2 Liter Leitungswasser aber
das ist vom Preis her wirklich zu
vernachlässigen bedeutet an rein
Materialkosten sind wir bei 5,66 € pro
Modell was richtig gut ist gerade wenn
man den Verkaufspreis betrachtet der bei
125 € liegt nach 10% Rabatt den wir beim
Checkout geben landet man bei
112,41 Cent und das alles voneinander
abgezogen bedeutet 106 € und 75 Cent
gewinnen
Luxus spielt ja bekanntlich nach eigenen
Regeln und das hat mir dieses Produkt
auf jeden Fall wieder gezeigt Daniel
arschem Skulpturen bear bricks gehen für
hunderte oder tausende Euro über die
Ladentheke und sind im Zweifelsfall
nicht mal handgemacht sondern sind
Massenprodukte aus Plastik es ist eben
Kunst es ist ein Wohlbefinden dass man
sich kauft das ist ein
Einrichtungsgegenstand und das ist dann
nicht mehr an rationale Preisgestaltung
gebunden sondern das ist wert was Leute
bereit sind zu zahlen und wenn man es
wirklich genau nimmt stimmt die
Rentabilitätsrechnung auch nicht weil
wir haben ja eine Menge Zeit und vor
allem auch eine Menge Kohle in die
Entwicklung und Produktion der Formen
gesteckt 655 € und 64 Cent benutzt sein
das bedeutet wir müssen mindestens mal
sechs Produkte 6 Kulturen sechs Porsche
Modelle verkaufen um überhaupt Break
Even zu sein anders gerechnet geht man
z.B davon aus zehn Modelle insgesamt zu
verkaufen hätte man Kosten von 712 € und
24 Cent was insgesamt einen Preis pro
Modell von 71 € und 22 Cent macht und
das hört sich jetzt natürlich schon
wieder anders an als die 5,66 € die ich
euch gerade eben in der unbereinigten
entertitätsrechnung gezeigt habe und
natürlich sinkt der Preis desto mehr
Modelle wir verkaufen und produzieren
das zum Beispiel hier sind alle Preise
pro Modell bei 10 20 50 100 und 1000
verkaufen
genau jetzt startet die Massenproduktion
glücklicherweise muss man den Modellen
nicht beim Trocknen zuschauen das
bedeutet wir können in wenigen Minuten
die Masse abwiegen anmischen
reinschütten und nach einer Stunde schon
die fertigen Modelle rausholen und das
ist ziemlich verrückt für die Masse
braucht man nämlich keinen Ofen um es
irgendwie zu trocknen und es dauert auch
nicht 24 Stunden das aushärtet sondern
nach einer Stunde ist es quasi fertig
und kann draußen an der Luft weiter
trocknen und die Form sind wieder frei
an einem normalen Arbeitstag von 8
Stunden schaffen wir also ca 25 Modelle
insgesamt eine Stunde wirklich Arbeit
und 7 Stunden darauf warten dass die
Modelle einfach getrocknet sind und das
beste keiner von uns muss an irgendeiner
Laden stehen keiner von uns muss
irgendwelche Sachen ausliefern wie im
blumenvideo sondern während dem
Produzieren der Modelle kann das hier
passieren mein Handy findet mit genau
diesen Sound denn genau in diesem Moment
16:36 Uhr gerade einfach verkauft ein
Porsche Modell 124,90 €, das bedeutet zu
den beiden Paketen die wir gerade
verpackt haben wir jetzt direkt noch
eins das Beste
besser waren keine fünf Minuten später
Tom du Ehrenmann Toyota super Poster
läuft jetzt alles über einen Job beste
leben
112 Euro und 41 Cent bester Mann einfach
mit fucking tiktoks und das war erst der
Anfang alles sales die ihr gerade
gesehen habt kam in wenigen Minuten das
erste tiktok das wirklich funktioniert
hat hat und so unheimlich viele Shop
Besuche und auch Verkäufe gebracht das
war völlig geisteskrank kurze Meldung
aus dem Schnitt um genau zu sein 6000
Shop Besuche und über 16 Bestellung und
das ohne Werbung einfach nur mit
organischen tiktoks und das beste alle
tiktoks die danach kam gingen im Prinzip
nur noch mehr ab und obwohl ich schon so
oft gesagt habe Fragen immer noch Leute
wir nutzen natürlich shopify das ist das
krasseste Tool das ist überhaupt gibt
jeder von euch kann damit Online Shops
erstellen und machen was auch immer man
möchte niemand eigene Produkte was auch
immer Links dazu sind in der
Videobeschreibung gibt 14 Tage
kostenlose Testversion und ist einfach
mit Abstand das beste tun für Online
Shops es geht an Verpacken der orders
und das nur aus den letzten Tagen wir
sehen ne direktation zwischen gut
funktionierenden tiktoks ja die tiktoks
haben geisteskrank funktioniert und
bestellten Autos wie viele genau erfahrt
ihr am Ende des Videos so viel kann ich
aber schon mal sagen es gibt
Bestellungen in den einzelnen Leute 4
Modelle auf einmal gekauft haben also
über 400 € Umsatz in einer Bestellung
weißher Gott warum aber wir wollen uns
natürlich nicht beschweren Sticker drauf
Paket Falten zukleben Modell rein in
Bubble Rap oben zu machen und noch ein
paar Stecker reinschmeißen und das für
alle oh das ist schon da sind und noch
kommen
das Problem ist ich kann euch natürlich
nichts zeigen wirklich in shopify
datenschutzmäßig wer sind unsere Kunden
und so weiter aber das hier sind die
Orders der letzten Tage die ist für uns
auszuführen gilt guckt euch das an
449,64 € 22
[Musik]
wir haben alles durchgepackt
der Weile ist richtig geil wir müssen
die Etiketten nicht mal mehr ausdrucken
wir gehen dahin kaufen vorher die
Etiketten mit so einem QR-Code gehen
vorne zum DHL Mann und sagen hier
QR Code DHL Mann eine Dose der Scan
nimmt das Paket klebt das drauf und ob
das jetzt let's go
alle Pakete Weg the moment
ist gestern Abend von online gegangen
das Problem ist ich habe momentan kein
Instagram also ich habe gar nicht
mitbekommen und ich konnte heute Morgen
nach dem Aufstehen aber ja schon die
ganzen notifications sehen das ist
funktioniert hat aber wie gut müssen wir
jetzt gemeinsam schauen wir haben halt
übelst den Rabatt gegeben also 25 % in
der Story mit wir haben drei zehn
Bestellungen seit gestern Abend 22 Uhr
wo das placement online gegangen ist wir
haben jetzt 11:30 Uhr das bedeutet das
placement ist noch mal 12 Stunden online
und das weniger wo die Leute schlafen
sondern da wo die Leute den ganzen Tag
wach sind
ja man könnte fast meinen dass
influencer Marketing tatsächlich
funktioniert so und damit ihr seht in
welchen Abständen die sales hier
reinkommen stelle ich jetzt die Kamera
hier auf und wir beobachten das Handy
gemeinsam
[Musik]
komm hier
ist leicht besser als ich gehofft habe
ich denke das war's also nicht mit
Verkäufen aber mit der Demonstration
unserer Verkäufe irgendwann habe ich
auch gemerkt dass wir hier gefährlich
nah ans Ende von Porsche Trailer kommen
was mein absolutes hölzername war weil
ich so viele weitere Ideen habe ich
gerne mit in diese Staffel eingebaut
hätte auf der anderen Seite habe ich vor
allem in den ersten Videos sehr häufig
in den Kommentaren gelesen dass ich
viele von euch ein wirkliches trade also
ein ein tauschformat gewünscht hätten
und da jetzt die Frage habt ihr
tatsächlich Lust auf eine Staffel 3
vielleicht nicht diesen Monat vielleicht
nicht dieses Jahr aber habt ihr
grundsätzlich Lust auf eine Staffel 3
wenn ja lasse ich mich in den
Kommentaren wissen wenn es genug Leute
sind dann kann ich mir tatsächlich
vorstellen dass noch mal zu machen bevor
wir jetzt zu irgendwas kommen ein riesen
riesen Danke schön an jeden einzelnen
von euch der diese Serie unterstützt hat
im Hintergrund ihr seht vielleicht
stehen einige um genau zu sein 100
kleine Modelle die wir in den letzten
Tagen genauso wie die großen Modelle
selber gegossen haben diese Modelle sind
genau wie die Golfbälle kostenlos über
den ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
zu finden also seid schnell und probiert
irgendwie auf diese Website zu kommen
das Passwort verbirgt sich in diesem
Video kommen wir jetzt aber zu den
Umsätzen tatsächlich sind es nicht nur
Umsätze aus dieser Folge sondern eine
der vorangegangenen Folgen prägt einen
riesen Teil dazu bei und zwar der
Postershop der war die ganze Zeit weiter
mit online und das war auch die Website
über die wir die Porsche Modelle
verkauft haben und eine Menge Leute
haben weiter Poster gekauft sogar mehr
als vorher insgesamt konnten wir nämlich
nach dem letzten Update zum Postershop
noch Umsätze in Höhe von
2.495 € und 20 Cent erzielen mit Gelato
Kosten also dafür dass es gedruckt wird
dieses von 855 € und Werbung in Höhe von
173 € die wir geschaltet haben was kommt
komplett geisteskrank ist weil wir das
einfach von zu Hause mit einem Laptop so
auf die Beine stellen kommt jetzt aber
zum grand-finale was konnten wir mit
Porsche und Graffiti Modellen verdienen
das hier sind insgesamt die Kosten
darunter keramasse Paket dicker
das ganze andere scheiß und eben auch
das placement bei mowo wir können es
euch nicht genauer aufschlüsseln weil
wir natürlich nicht die genauen Kosten
den verhandelten Preis mit movo und so
preisgeben können und wollen deswegen
müssen wir damit leben aber jetzt zu den
Umsätzen und das ist völlig Geist
alleine an den Graffiti Modellen haben
wir
4008 Euro und 26 Cent Umsatz gemacht das
ist schon eine Menge aber nichts im
Vergleich zu dem Porschen die wir über
die letzten 30 Tage oder seit wann das
auch immer online war so oft verkauft
haben das ist zu einem Umsatz von
8.233 € und 30 Cent führt was so viel
ist dass ich mir wünschen würde dass es
nicht so viel wert damit wir weitere
Folgen machen es ist aber wie es ist und
das bedeutet das genau hier Porsche
Trader und damit Trader Staffel 2 zu
einem Ende angefangen beim
golfballtauchen was ein absolutes
Highlight war und wahrscheinlich sogar
mein Favorite Video insgesamt auf meinem
Kanal geworden ist das so gut
funktioniert hat dass wir selber nicht
damit gerechnet hätten weiter so unlog
ist wo wir hunderte von Kilometern
gefahren sind über die verrückte Idee
mit AI vollautomatisiert Geld zu
verdienen in der wir keinen Cent
verdient haben weiter zum Postershop den
wir alleine mit einem Rechner von zu
Hause aus aufgezogen haben zu Blumen am
Muttertag verkaufen und jetzt zu den
Porschen Modellen es ist eine
unglaubliche Reise gewesen und ich
möchte mich am liebsten bei jedem von
euch einzeln bedanken weil das aber
nicht geht mache ich einfach weiter
Content und probiere euch weiter zu
unterhalten und im nächsten Videos geht
es darum einen Porsche zu kaufen einen
Porsche umzubauen und mit ihm auf große
Reise durch ganz Europa zu gehen wenn
ihr das also nicht verpassen wollt dann
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
dem Video ein Like dazu lassen dann
sehen wir uns in den nächsten Wochen
wieder oder in den nächsten Monaten oder
Jahren so weiteren verrückten Projekt
macht's gut das war Porsche Trader
Staffel 2